[Music]
nice to meet you you too
i'm sorry oh it didn't turn red yet no
i'm so sorry
yes
i'm so sorry i'm so sorry but the button
hasn't activated yet
god damn
[Laughter]
you know this is like just like when one
rejected dude in person but he doesn't
leave mm-hmm so it's like i'm not
interested i'm not interested i'm not
interested oh my god he's still here he
won't leave so
okay okay
do you find each other attractive
[Music]
you know what's funny about the button
is the button isn't that different from
real life it's just in your face there's
definitely been times where i've
approached her good i'm like i mean
she's waiting for the first exit to get
out of this conversation
let me just leave now without saying
you're explaining anything and we'll
both be happy
why talk to me talk to me
this thing about like president obama is
so nice that you should just
damn it yeah i don't really like guys
with long hair
hi hello emily ryan was in the army
you're in the army i was in the army
yeah from 2012 to 2016.
oh
maybe it was the army that did it maybe
some women are so like uh oh you're in
the army yeah wasn't your [__]
oh don't worry why did you press me i
don't know man something about army guys
what do you what do you do for fun what
do i do for fun video games mostly video
games
what kind of video games
the big um so the last one i put
got me all right why did you reject him
because there's more to life than video
games man i want to hear this bitch's
hobby because she seemed like she
probably dull as [__] hi
is it your mission to get me out is
everyone like angry well i don't know i
don't know about that i've heard about
you though
[Applause]
get the [__] out of here
all right i heard a lot about you one
time
[__] out of here
yeah d block yeah and d stands for dude
block okay pause that sounds good
next date please
hi
my name is taylor
they got a whole ass furry in there ruff
ruff the cut get the weirdest [__]
people on this furry's gonna get the
[__] out i just dress up and i put
smiles in people's faces so do you have
like multiple or is it i only have one
i did it first
button
they undid the whole last button
i'm a furry yes
video game sounds nice now huh
i'm patty i'm patrick nice to meet you
patrick and penny yeah
i'm patrick
patrick
oh that was a sign of her [__] popping
yeah it popped a bit patty are you a
virgin
a virgin
[Music]
dude's face
my man look like an extra in a white
cleft jaw video refugee faces
[Laughter]
no i'm not are you a virgin
yes i am oh okay we are just passing
legislation against virginity and sodomy
we do not want it virginity is a
sickness it is deviant therefore we want
it out of our country
as a human rights activist we have asked
you patrick for what reason have you
admitted to being a virgin
do you usually have to tell people that
first off the bat on a date usually just
kids
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you for the service yeah
the moment
is it because she's not a virgin
no it's because she's older than me how
do you know ah i can tell
[Laughter]
i have seen enough white women in my
life
i know when they have gone past you
like a ripe avocado it has gone brown at
the wrong time
okay it is like getting an apple looks
fine on the outside then you touch it
you go
no my friends
we have good fruit in africa for that
reason do i come to a better life to eat
fruit from back home
for what reason do i come to a better
life to eat fruit from the future i am
in the present i do not want the past i
want be right now my friend you are past
due that means that you have gone too
far to the future that you are in my
past
think about it it is quite wise
you should play incoming america it is
we're going to continue huh i'm not
going to stay on this point too long eh
white women if you are watching i'm
sorry you have become an unnecessary
casualty of war
it's okay if your feelings are hurt
imagine black people in colonization
you are going to make it the same way we
have made it we are here today you're a
pastor
that's a bar though
you're so far into the future you're in
my past
[Music]
because if you think about it that's
what a [__] fruit is
it has gone so long that it is behind
you in the sense that you don't want it
no more you get me
a fruit is only good for the present
when it is ripe
my friend you are laughing huh
it is because the knowledge has not
entered your cranium
the haitian people you guys were taking
over hey
[Applause]
no no that's not the problem i admire
the haitian people huh don't start with
the haters bro yes i advise the haitian
people
i admire the haitian people
if i'm being honest
all the haitians are looking like hey
[__] wait till you come my city
[__] you up
let's continue can you tell me more
about yourself uh i'm a student
how do you i'm 23.
what's your dating age range above 25
and then stopping at like 36. in your
voice i detected a slight lisp
you have gotten me quite excited
oh yeah you like when they sound wet
yes
moisture keeps everything lubricated
makes the engine run smooth
my friend
later on if we are going to go sleep and
slide we do not need to go to the park
yeah having a field trip with this one
today's video is brought to you by lilo
that's how you're gonna react when
you're gonna use the new lilo wave what
is this well it's it's just if you want
a gentle two finger massage the lilo
idle wave is there for you watch this
it moves
you gotta move like jagger
and it's totally waterproof so you can
have a little bit more fun in the shower
if we're being honest sometimes we get
tired we can't always be involved in our
partner's pleasure maybe they're
traveling maybe we're tired it's been a
long work day so that's why this makes
us a great tool it lets her know that
you care about her pleasure even when
you're not involved and for the ladies
watching well i mean hey you know
you deserve to be happy take control
assert your own independence get one of
these and make sure you show yourself a
good time you want to know why because
you deserve it
i said it i see you i'm watching you not
literally figuratively you deserve it
perfect shape is all smooth and soft you
can control it with your bluetooth app
there's an app they have an app yeah you
have ten different settings it is a
hundred percent waterproof and you can
control it well with the bluetooth app
you just download the app and then you
control that and that's i'm sorry i'm
having flashbacks
anyways get yours today by clicking on
the link below
you have a nice on this tv you do too
are you from l.a i'm originally from
uganda okay i was born there i moved out
here when i was like one do you like to
dance i like to dance what about you no
i just was having fun i cannot dance at
all everybody can dance no everybody
[Music]
we could be friends i
direct
i heard but direct
you have made a mistake
uganda you arrived on this scene your
previous african brother had already
been rejected instead you take time to
mingle with the heathen
in solidarity you should have arrived
and hit the button and said big on wench
this is
yes instead uganda said i've immigrated
i don't need my people anymore guess
what now you are by yourself and lonely
go home masturbate
oh sorry oh it didn't turn red yet no
i'm so sorry i'm so sorry
tell me about yourself okay
i'm gabrielle
y'all shout out to this guy
cool this guy is collecting murderer he
said [__] i know my reflex faster than
you so go ahead just tell me about your
stuff before i boot you out this
[__]
so tell me about yourself go ahead talk
girl
yeah
just know
you're about to get the long slung of
this white mane cool calm and collected
i like that [__] yeah
you thought it was on like donkey kong
now don't make me [__] eat my words
and not hit the button before her better
don't just sit there asking about
herself she's been hitting the eject
button
give each other a chance yeah let's give
each other a chance let's let's okay you
want to do that i do see you as a friend
though no
that is correct
anyone you look straight put that [__]
back yeah that's your back yeah the way
he looked at her when he buzzed that
whoo revenge was sweet look at that [__]
see you as a friend though no
she went i i do see you as a friend as
his head was come up hey what you see
his face it goes
that's some dexter [__] that that dude
is real-life dexter yeah she was trying
to friends on him while she was trying
to eject him yeah come on [__] anyway
no no get your [__] i do [__] listen
that's why when girls say yo
i want you to appreciate that's why when
girls say i do see you as your friend
it's just their way of saying i'd never
date you but you you like you i i could
use you for attention you know what i'm
saying
oh what you doing tomorrow
okay you want to hear about my day in my
life okay
you want to take me out to dinner and
you pay okay yeah
just know
all right how's your day going i'm doing
pretty good i got pressed so fast last
time oh you've you've been here before
like you've done it we went through the
whole thing over like oh wow really
looping back around yeah why do you
think you got x before
um
well i don't think we found each other
attractive oh okay
i said it and she
and she
didn't i thought you were about to do it
so i thought you about i was i was like
i i won't do it quickly if you don't do
it okay can we make a truce sure why are
humans so scared of rejection
rejection sucks who would like it right
and i think like most people are pretty
egocentric so like rejection is part of
that
i think i think we think that it
reflects something about us as a person
sometimes
i know it
let's call the truce let's not touch it
too quickly
the moment that [__] turned red she
said
she said bye
that minute
okay you're vindictive my girl bro i
think this is way worse than the other
ones because they just spent like two
minutes talking about remember it's
actually hurt so bad like really
rejected you know and it's one of those
things where it's like you don't want to
have to do but we're all a little
egocentric so
we're just
[Laughter]
i feel like with this show what it
really exposes is that people could put
on such good faces about like oh i
really care i really care i i really
like there's just something fascinating
by that time like oh so tell me about
man yeah
so your dogs whoa [__] can we not have
a human moment tell me you tell me more
about yang
but it shows you people are very phony
hello hi i'm ryan i'm kat nice to meet
you nice to meet you hello
um i'm a software engineer oh wow what
do you do i do construction or like a
carpentry i lay wood and decks and you
build stuff that's interesting i do yeah
i like wood
this i don't know what it is about women
but they find out you work with your
hands
with your hands huh bro
bro
how do you feel about two fingers bro
when you do [__] around the house
and shit's going to look good did i ever
tell you one of the fantasies the girl
told me she said i would think it was so
sexy if i was in my house making some
lemonade and i went outside my man was
working on the car all oily with just
car engine parts all over him and then i
came out
like you know like the oil from a car
okay car engine parts i don't know how
did they incorporate on one like
someone's like a carburetor like
differential here like hey what up you
took sexy
[Laughter]
honey honey honey honey can you find my
wrench
yeah yeah you told me about that [__] if
i built something it'd fall over so well
kudos
i can teach you
mine's kind of cute
you're very attractive
you're yeah you're very very attractive
and you're a
software engineer that's way smarter
than me what turns you guys on what
turns you on yes
um depends on the situation it's like oh
he can fix something like that
that's a wrap
we're good it's a wrap
and i just need you guys to know and i
ain't mad at me we don't pre-watch this
stuff
so when i'm saying this [__] i'm not
making under this i'm not telling you
what i heard from other people i know
i know because i don't work with my
hands the girls ask you how do you work
with your hands i see the excitement
cause they just want an extra reason to
like me and i love just being like nah
[__] i pay somebody else to do that's
how real [__] do so
you know it is what it is
she's like you don't want to learn no i
don't
you don't fight it no i don't
preach is more than you know he's into
that stuff because i was broke once
yeah i was broke too i just i just
walked my ass to work
i said word i can't afford this [__] if
we can't afford to change your brakes
change your brakes man the difference
it's like a it's a difference it's going
to take you longer but [__]
like the oh i'm resourceful but i'm
resourceful in a way that people don't
find sexy mm-hmm
i can find them for you
that's me bro if it's internet [__]
what's your name you need to find the
facts of the case
there you go you want me to type 100
words a minute i got you
right everyone got the thing well i i i
listen i tell girls i type 100 words a
minute of their life mm-hmm
so you play video games
that's pretty much what they think
no cap they don't give a [__] so
that is what it is they really don't you
got to know your strengths and you got
to know your weaknesses then you got to
adjust accordingly you know i was too
much of a [__] geeky nerd so what i
do i learn how to dance women love that
[__] it is what it is when i first
learned how to dance it was just for
that reason
and then you know obviously now i enjoy
it more for me it's something i do on
the regular by myself but back when i
started i hate when people kept like you
go there to meet women
it is what it is at my line no i can't
understand people like no no i do for
the left i bet you lie
but it's okay anything you want to say
no
what did you guys think of today's
episode
yeah that was a bar what i gave you
earlier was a bar no it's not a bar let
us know in the comments that was
it it's not a